California's in a drought yeah they've
been in a dread I don't know if they're
still in a drought but the drought comes
and goes basically Southern California
is a desert and they're only surviving
off of Colorado River water for the most
part so hey these people who live down
there are like I shouldn't have to do
this everyone else should have to and
it's like dude they would have swimming
pools don't they so if there's such a
drought you know give up your swimming
pool for the summer well there were
several celebrities that were running
their Sprinklers and they would get
fined so they were just doing it anyways
because they can afford to pay the fine
so why should their lifestyle suffer
yeah but you guys should all start using
you know reusable pla or like the paper
straws because that will save the
environment and that's ridiculous
because you go to Starbucks you get a
coffee it's in a massive plastic cup and
then you've got the paper straw which is
just you know so hypocritical so it's
just virtue signaling at the end of the
day because how's that saving the planet
if you're still using a plastic cup it
was because they found that tortoise
that giant turtle with the straw stuck
in his nose did you ever see that video
yeah and they have like pliers trying to
pull it out it's bleeding